My name is Amina. I'm working as a cler
in an industry. My question is shik is
the major scene that that we do believe
that we'll enter janam but
>> I cannot understand you. Can you speak
closer to the microphone and slowly
>> shout?
>> My name is Amina.
>> Amina. My yeah my question is shik is
the major sin that when you commit you
enter hellf fire. My question is what
about those who they are not being
exposed to they are not they didn't find
knowledge but they died like for
instance in Indians those who are
woriing idols what about those kids who
died before knowing that shik is woriing
idols is the shik
>> sister asked a question that shik is the
major sin in Islam and she's correct
she's asking What about those
non-Muslims who without getting the
message of Islam they die worshiing shik
what will happen like in India I don't
know anyone in India who has not got the
message I was in India for many years I
don't know anyone in India who has not
get the message of Islam I don't know
you know anyone I don't know anyone
>> okay
>> the thing is that Allah says in the
Quran in surah fill chapter number 41
verse number 53 three
that soon we shall show them our signs
in the furthest region of the horizon
and into their soul until it is clear to
them that this is the truth. That means
Allah says in the Quran he HIMSELF WILL
GIVE EVERY human being the message
until it is clear to them this is the
truth. So whether you do dawa OR NOT,
WHETHER I do dawa OR NOT, ALLAH SAYS in
the Quran, he will GIVE THE MESSAGE OF
ONENESS of Allah HIMSELF TO EVERY HUMAN
BEING. No excuse. But after that when
you come to know there's one god. Oh, if
there's one god I'll have to give up
alcohol, I'll have to give up pork. Oh,
why should we give up all these good
things? He may accept Islam may not
accept Islam. So no one can give the
excuse today
in this age of science and technology
when media is so common
to say that he did not get the message.
So today anyone seeing in the world that
he has not got the message is difficult.
But people in the past there were two
tribes Kapu tribe and the tribe of
Australian aborigence. They did not come
in contact with modern civilization till
as late as 1950 when people went and
interrogated them. They found they were
following everything of Islam except in
name. They believed in one God. They
believed God had no image. They did the
saga sujudus for for worship. It was
everything of Islam except in name. So
if you as the beloved PROPHET SAID EVERY
CHILD is born in later on he is he is
influenced by his parents
then he starts doing idol worship fire
worship then he converts from a Muslim
to a non-Muslim. That's the reason when
a non-Muslim becomes a Muslim we call
him revert coming back to Islam. So
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala makes every
human being born in din later on they
get converted to become a non-Muslim we
have to do dawa and get them to Islam
whether we do dawa or not Allah himself
gives the message directly in surah
fusil 41:53
so on the day of judgment they cannot
say that I did not receive the message
but we as Muslims we should try and
convey to as many non-Muslims as we can
so that we get sab we get plus points so
that we go to Jenna and the hope that
answers the